pendant près de huit heures hier soir et
jusqu'à plus de 5 heures ce matin nous
avons débattu des mesures que vous
proposez pour protéger les français face
aux actes terroristes mais je promets ni
du ressort de ce débat avec un sentiment
d'amertume d'indignation et aussi de
colère au-delà de votre posture de votre
ton martial de vos coups de sang de
votre assurance qui confine à
l'arrogance pas le début de commencement
de mea culpa de votre part de celle du
président de la république ou de votre
ministre de l'intérieur pas une fois
vous n'avez eu le moindre regret pour
des mesures que vous n'auriez pas prise
et qui aurait pu limiter prévenir ou
empêcher le drame de nice
que proposez vous aux français pour les
protège aujourd'hui en dehors de la
prolongation d'état d'urgence rien à
situation exceptionnelle nous proposons
des mesures exceptionnelles prises par
de nombreux autres pays qui sont tout
autant que nous des pays de droit
permettre le contrôle d'identité par les
policiers municipaux refusent et
permettre à la police municipale de
disposer des mêmes armes que la police
nationale refuse à mettre en place des
centres de rétention sur les fichiers s
refusé expulsé notre territoire national
et étranger condamné refusé supprimer
toutes prestations sociales un
terroriste et sa famille refuse et
permettre la fouille des véhicules par
la police sans réquisition préalable
refusé interdire le financement des
lieux de culte par des puissances
étrangères refuse et revoir la loi sur
la légitime défense des policiers
refusent et fermer les mosquées
salafistes ou prêchant la haine refusé
allonger la durée d'assignation à
résidence
refusez interdire le retour sur le
territoire national de dialyse
binationaux partie l'étranger semer la
mort refusez supprimer l'automaticité de
réduction de peine pour les personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme
refusez réorienter notre politique pour
lutter avec la russie contre l'état
islamique refuse et je me suis dit c'est
voeckler dans le pays une colère qui
monte
entendez là et agissez la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre manuel
valls
monsieur le député yves nicolin non non
vous pouvez penser que les d'hier
d'ailleurs à la tribune en présentant
l'approbation de l'état d'urgence le
ministre de l'intérieur et parce que
j'ai occupé aussi ses fonctions je sais
je peux imaginer qu'elles sont pour en
parler avec lui
ces réflexions actuellement moi même
comme chef du gouvernement
le président de la république bien sûr
avec les g que nous venons de connaître
avec ses victimes
ces corps sur la promenade des anglais
s'est blessé que nous avons vu à
l'hôpital de nice ses cris de douleur la
colère bien sûr vous croyez que nous
interrogeons pas un seul instant pensé
d'abord que comme des êtres humains nous
posons pas des questions sur tout ce qui
a été fait pas fait pour empêcher ces
drames nous prenez pour qui
penser que nous n'avons pas un moment de
conscience et que nous nous posons pas
monsieur le député les questions
fondamentales
parce que tous ceux qui ont eu
l'occasion de gouverner tous je m'en
rappelle moi du visage du président la
république à l'époque nicolas sarkozy
j'imagine ce qu'il pouvait endurer comme
le président de la république françois
hollande quand dans la cour des
invalides
on se trouve face à des cercueils de
militaires suite aux décisions qui sont
prises par des chefs de l'état eh bien
nous aussi nous avons évidemment ce
questionnement mais nous savons en même
temps qu'à travers tous les débats que
nous avons eus ici à l'assemblée
nationale que tout ce que nous avons
engagé je les rappelle tout à l'heure je
n'y reviens pas vise et visera toujours
à protéger les français nous sommes
engagés nous engageons tous les moyens à
100% pour protéger les français et en
même temps nous devons cette vérité que
je rappelais aux français sur les
risques existent sur ce qu'est la nature
de ce terrorisme du jihadisme de
l'islamisme radical
nous l'avons qualifiés et parce que nous
l'avons qualifier nous sommes ensuite
plus fort pour pouvoir prendre tous les
dispositifs il y à un débat il est
légitime dans le
et je pourrais monsieur le député je les
fais d'ailleurs hier et d'une certaine
manière les uns et les autres nous
pouvons céder à cette facilité mais
c'est aussi un devoir d'exigence et de
vérité rappeler ce qui a été fait depuis
2012 comme rappelé ce qui n'avait pas
été fait avant 2012 rappeler ceux qui
ont pris la responsabilité de supprimer
près de 10000 de près de 13 mille postes
de policiers et de gendarmes de ce pays
ceux qui ont supprimé renseignements
généraux ceux qui ont baissé les moyens
de nos forces de sécurité et de nos
forces de l'ordre je pourrais évidemment
et c'est tellement facile et c'est
tellement facile et en même temps
monsieur le député
c'est tellement vrai et moi ce que je
refuse monsieur le député c'est la
facilité c'est la démagogie est
précisément parce que notre pays est
confronté
un défi nous devons être exigeants les
uns et les autres nous devons être unis
pas pour être punis tout simplement
parce que le gouvernement souhaiterait
l'unité nationale mais parce que le
terrorisme monsieur le député et mettez
vous bien ça dans la tête veut nous
diviser
il veut nous diviser ils veulent ou
fracturés et bien au lieu de nous
diviser
soyons capables de nous rassembler sur
l'essentiel nous l'avons fait cette nuit
en votant une très large majorité le
prolongement de l'état d'urgence en
intégrant des amendements de la majorité
comme de l'opposition
c'est cette vision des choses que je
veux parce que moi je crois à la
noblesse de la politique et je crois
qu'avec cette action avec celle noblesse
et avec ce rassemblement nous vaincrons
monsieur le député nicollin le
terrorisme c'est en tout cas ma
conception l'action politique merci
monsieur le premier ministre